ya sabemos que la derivada con respecto
a x de tangente de x es igual a la
secante de x al cuadrado lo cual por
supuesto es igual a 1 sobre el coseno de
x al cuadrado lo que quiero que hagamos
en este vídeo como hemos hecho en los
vídeos anteriores es calcular la
derivada con respecto a x de la tangente
inversa de x es decir queremos calcular
la derivada con respecto a x de la
tangente inversa de x y te invito a que
le pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes
usando una técnica similar a la que
usamos en los vídeos anteriores calcular
cuánto vale esta derivada bien
hagamos que igual a tangente inversa de
x esto equivale a establecer a decir que
tangente de y es igual a equis y puedes
imaginarte que estás tomando tangente a
ambos lados para obtener entonces que
tangente de y es igual a equis derivamos
entonces con respecto a x ambos lados
derivamos con respecto a x ambos lados y
que obtenemos del lado izquierdo
aplicando la regla de la cadena la
derivada de tangente de iu es secante
cuadrada de y que podemos escribir la
deriva de tangente de jessica anticuada
de ella que puedo escribir como uno
sobre coseno cuado de y yo prefiero
escribirlo de esta manera como que mi
mente identifica mejor esta expresión
así es que esto es la deriva de tangente
de y por aplicando la regla de la cadena
la derivada de ye con respecto a x por d
y én de x
y esto es igual esto es igual a la
derivada de x con respecto a x que es 1
y ahora vamos a despejar de jane de x
multiplicando ambos lados por coseno
cuadrada y hacemos eso entonces para
obtener que deje en de x es igual
coseno del elevado al cuadrado y como
nos ha pasado en vídeos anteriores esto
no nos sirve pues tenemos de jane de x
como una función de y cuando en realidad
la necesitamos como una función de x lo
que tenemos que hacer ahora es expresar
esto de alguna manera como tangente de y
pues ya sabemos que tangente de iu es
igual a equis así es que vamos a
reescribir esto usando identidades
trigonométricas para posteriormente
sustituir en vez de tangente de x
veamos cómo hacemos eso aunque esto no
parece inmediato sabemos qué tangente de
jesse no sobre coseno pero como
introducimos aquí tangente pues sólo
tenemos simplemente coseno de y se me
hace que para este vídeo vamos a
requerir más experimentación de lo que
hicimos en los dos ejemplos anteriores
algo que podemos hacer es dividir entre
1 dividir entre 1 nunca afecta una
expresión así es que vamos a dividir
entre 1 así es que esto lo puedo
escribir como coseno cuadrado de ella y
esto
estoy haciendo para escribir esto como
una expresión racional esperando que en
algún momento dado obtenga seno sobre
coseno que permita sustituirlo por
tangente así es que dividimos entre 1 y
aquí podemos aplicar la identidad
pitagórica 1 es igual a seno cuadrado de
y más coseno cuadro de y esto es
entonces coseno cuadrado de i + seno
cuadrado de y de nueva cuenta esto lo
puedo hacer pues esta y la identidad
pitagórica que surge esencialmente del
círculo unitario donde se definen todas
las funciones trigonométricas esto es
igual a 1 no he cambiado el valor de la
expresión lo que es interesante aquí es
que si requiere un seno dividido entre
un coche no lo que puedo hacer es
dividir numerador y denominador entre
coseno cuadrado de y hagamos eso
dividimos entonces el numerador entre
coseno cuadrado de iu y dividimos el
denominador entre coseno cuando deje o
multiplicamos por uno entre coseno
cuando del numerador y denominador y que
obtenemos en el numerador coseno cuadro
de y entre
en el cuadro de y nos da 1 y en el
denominador coseno cual de gente con
seno cuando llenos da uno más seno
cuadrado de i
seno cuadrado del sobre
sobre coseno cuadrado de y sobre coseno
cuadrado de y que era lo que queríamos
queríamos se nos sobrecoge no aquí
tenemos en ecuador de jets sobre coseno
al cuadro de iu y esto es lo mismo que
vamos a ponerlo en la siguiente manera
déjame escribir esto de la siguiente
manera para que lo veamos más claramente
esto lo mismo que seno de iu sobre
coseno de iu y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado ahora sí esto es igual a uno
sobre uno más seno de iu sobre coseno de
yes tangente del elevado al cuadrado
esto es igual a esto y eso porque es
útil bueno sabemos qué tangente de iu es
igual a equis así es que esto va a ser
igual esto va a ser igual a
a 1 sobre 1 + tangente de jacques x 1 +
x elevado al cuadrado lo cual es
realmente emocionante ya hemos calculado
la derivada de ye con respecto a x así
es que la derivada de esto con respecto
a x es igual a 1 sobre 1 + x cuadrada
escribamos eso acá arriba la derivada
con respecto a x de la tangente inversa
de x es igual a 1 + 1 sobre x cuadrada y
así hemos concluido